as you could as you could
ascertained from the lecture that the
whole question of secularization is a
rather complex one if there's a story to
be told about this lecture is that the
processes ought not to be understood in
a simple linear way from a kind of
primitive religion race of religion to
the light of Reason shining into the
dark corners of of religious minds and
dispelling it and therefore a progress
being identified with secularization but
rather the story to be told is much more
complex one of various versions of it
you have read in in in the assigned
readings and some attempt at explaining
how do we understand modernity you could
also find in Charles Taylor's piece to
alternative maternities I realized that
this was probably the most difficult
text to read because it was conceptually
- I suppose most most demanding but I
think it's also very useful text because
it explains precisely why the story of
modernization is not the one as Charles
Taylor later said and as Jose has
mentioned here as well one of
subtraction but rather has to be told in
a very different different way I wanted
to maybe start our discussion with with
two questions of Jose that that may that
are significant I think for our course
that are interesting to me that maybe
may suggest some trajectories of our
discussion but you feel free to take it
where you where you want to take it and
kind of puzzles that you that you have
about reading materials as well as the
lecture you can you can voiced and
certainly freely two issues that I
thought were interesting were three
actually issues I think it's important
to probe little bit more
the question of multiple modernities
that's one of the DS central issues
right if the old thesis counts right if
it's persuasive from primitive
religiosity to two to kind of erasure of
this religious superstructure and then
you have something like generic humanity
that remains and that's the story of
modernization that's the one kind of a
story but a different kind of story
might be well there are multiple ways to
modernize and you can be modern and
secular you could be modern as variously
religious now that will give you a very
much a different account of what's
happening in the world that will give
you a different account of the
relationship between faiths and
globalization processes that's very much
central to to the things that we are
going to be you doing in this course and
I realized that maybe there's no single
generally recognized answer to this
question people like Taylor people like
Professor Casanova advocate one position
there are there alternative ones but
it's very important for us to name this
and discuss it more I have clarity on
this the other thing is I think we
talked about resurgence of religion or
religions continuing to be alive and it
will be interesting now to to examine a
bit well what does that really mean
right
religions are alive as what or how do we
go about measuring this so that it's not
just an impression that we get because
media will descend 300 media outlets
they're going to descend to Greensville
to film what's going to happen in the
community of 50 right and then somehow
religion is alive right it's alive
because it's a particular egregious case
with significant implication of
implications but that's a different
common than saying that religions
broadly construed are alive so maybe
maybe a comment on how do we how do we
measure this how do we what are the
indicators of religions being alive
just a general question about this
presence of religion religions vibrancy
for individual individual believers as
well as kind of deep privatization or
religion not being private and that
brings me to another question that I
think is also very significant for our
for our course and that's the question
of is it as it seemed to be the case is
it true that religions are not just
simply alive if it's true but that they
also are increasingly or at least that
they're unwilling to remain and
privatized hidden in the privacy of
worshipers heart or of communities but
somehow are engaged in the public realm
and one of the indicators for instance
that that that might be of that is the
emergence of something that's called
engaged Buddhism so do you have a
religion which on the classical division
between prophetic religions which
receive the message of God to transform
the world and mystical religions which
are more associated with the flight of
the soul in the unity with the divine so
that even Buddhism who tended to be
classed as a mystical religion now is
understood and practiced as an engaged
religion that is somehow relevance of
religion for everyday life is is
reaffirmed by most of the religions if
that's the case that has implications in
terms of how one sees relationship
between globalization processes and and
religious community